you asked alexa lauda new gj
ooh gj yeah loud enough
okay there there is one someone asking
for tricky english lines
right oh yeah mr kawai khan
um was it yesterday it was yesterday
carlson played a really cool line
against hikaru in english
after e3 d5 takes takes
and then queen h5 um
and this is a this is a line i've never
seen before
and he just he won a pawn like right out
of the opening
i think what hikaru did was knight c6
and then knight b4 and then magnus just
took
play queen e4 defended c2 and he won
easily
so um so
that's one line usually you shouldn't
develop your queen early like this
but it's playable and black has to be
really careful against this
it's necessary to play queen d6 i think
either here
or here
you can also just play the bong cloud
i guess if you're hikaru
um yeah when i first heard
that he played it i didn't believe it
because i i wasn't following
i was a bit busy earlier today i wasn't
following the games live
what other tricky english lines
so a line i like to play is this and
then
a3 so the four knights english with a3
and against a lot of um i'll play a lot
of like amateur players
where like they'll play a5 to stop b4
i'll play e3
then they'll develop their bishop and
they'll walk into a center fork trick
and this line is nice for white it takes
and then d4
if they play bishop here you play c5 had
this position
a handful of times online once in a
tournament game
white's doing very well here
i can show one more tricky english line
it was a game i think karjakin on draken
or vice versa but it was a game
three nights english with g6 why play d4
takes in knight d5 let's find it
yeah okay on draken against karjakin
karjakin lost in
like 12 moves so knight d5 it's
it's playable um the idea is white
delays taking back the pawn
but control c squares with knight and
prepares bishop g5
so bishop g7 most played
and then bishop g5 and then karjakin
played a not so great move here
kuryakin played this even though it
looks natural it's just bad
last move was either knight ce7 or f6
but then the game proceeded andre can
unleash some cool tactics
first by taking here
um idea if knight takes we trap the
queen
so bishop takes d4
and now and now wait to move
let's see if chad can find the move
white to move find the win
okay suggestions for this and this
but yeah so ideally you
you want to get in this move but you
don't want to allow the bishop to take
so good job chat queen sacrifice queen
takes d4
and black can't take back because mate
in two
so black just lost like the most
important piece in the position
and now lights threatening made in two
so at this point black's already lost
karjakin castled here
and then yeah now now
there's a nice win for white i'll just
go ahead and show it
it's knight f6 um if kg7 it's very
simple we double check either with this
or more elegantly knight e8 um
neither the knight or the queen can be
taken
and then we made on g7
um so king h8 i believe was played
yeah and then in this position the
queen's attacked
so if you move your line anywhere you'll
allow
knight takes d4
however
i'll let jack find it i was gonna say it
but uh white to move and win
i think this is a nice puzzle for chat
i'll draw arrows
for any move that's suggested so we have
queen c3 knight h5
king d2 because you can't play king e2
that's logical
queen h4 knight g4
i will say one of these moves is correct
h7
the so the majority of chat has not
found it or is not suggesting the right
move
so i think i'll i'll go ahead and show
it cause it's really
good job the golf course
and everyone else lord schnapps i was
planning on continuing giving victory
bits for the rest of the stream but it's
all ready for 25 am here and i am
starting to drift off
so here's a bonus you are by far my
favorite chess streamer so glad i could
catch your stream
live so you're in europe so the the 5.92
cents was probably
converted from euros maybe thanks so
much
lord schnapps so yeah good job to
everyone who said knight g4
stacking a queen and draken found this
and then carjacking promptly resigned
given if flak takes a queen then
it's a nice checkmate
again with the bishop nightmate anyway
yeah so this is
actually this is probably one of the
first like miniature games i studied
when like starting to learn the english
and kind of inspired me to
to play this move order of the english
to try and get this line
anyway i hope people are inspired